Samsung just announced their latest
flagship tablet the tab s6 and I've got
to say that this is probably the best
tablet for replacing a laptop even
better than the iPad pro with its
impressive iPad OS update scheduled for
fully release this fall we'll talk about
exactly why the tab s6 is likely a
better choice in just a bit but first
let me tell you why I'm excited for him
just a few months ago Samsung released
the s5 II a budget tablet that I
genuinely really liked but told most
people not to buy it in my full review
but the s6 changes that suggestion
I love how thin and lightweight the s5 e
is the loud quad speakers and on top of
that the gorgeous AMOLED 16 by 10
display which is great for media
consumption with that said there were a
few big downsides that made it hard to
recommend the first was a Snapdragon 670
CPU which is mediocre for today's
standards and really worrisome if you
want to keep it for a few years paired
with a mid-range CPU is a weak GPU which
made gaming a very poor experience and
lastly there was no pen support which is
a deal-breaker for some people well the
new s6 fixed all of those things giving
us pen support like the previous tab s4
and a CPU that can handle everything you
throw at it they've made some physical
changes as well like removing the side
mounted fingerprint scanner opting for
an optical under display scanner I have
to say that this is a very interesting
choice given that their flagship phones
use ultrasonic scanners we also have an
updated keyboard and a new pen that's
included in the box which connects
magnetically on the back and along with
it on the back we have new dual cameras
one of them being a 5 megapixel ultra
wide lens even with these additions the
tablet is only 20 grams heavier than the
s5 II and only 5.7 millimeters thick
meaning that this will still be a
fantastic device for long handheld use
but this video isn't just about the
hardware but about how the new s hubby
is actually a better laptop replacement
than the iPad pro since Vadim recently
did a video on how the iPad pro is a
viable laptop replacement
I think that'll just be best to let him
take over and explain exactly why the
most important thing that can make the
Tab s 6 a better laptop replacement than
the iPad pro is a pretty amazing feature
called Samsung deck
it's basically an operating system
that's instantly accessible from an app
what's so special about it is that it
gives you full courser support and you
get a desktop layout that's very similar
to Windows 10 with the Start menu and
app shortcuts right on the desktop you
get incredible multitasking with
rearranged by windows and apps minimize
into the menu bar as well not only that
but you get traditional drag-and-drop
file storage support just like we're
used to on a Windows or Mac computer to
put the cherry on top the available
keyboard case actually comes with a
trackpad now we won't be able to tell
how well it works until we get the tab
as six into the office but the built-in
trackpad makes it feel so much more like
an actual laptop especially using
Samsung desks and while Apple's iPad
does get Mouse support it just mimics
touch input instead of actually
registering clicks so you can't really
use it like you would on a desktop
computer with the tab s6 though you can
plug it into an external monitor connect
a bluetooth mouse and keyboard internal
index to have a legitimate desktop
computer experience and to make it even
better the tap s6 comes with a stylus in
the box
unlike the Apple pencil which you have
to purchase separately for $130 the best
part is that the 256 gigabyte storage
model only cost seven hundred and twenty
nine dollars and it comes with eight
gigabytes of RAM compared to the iPad
pros four gigs of ram and if you buy the
keyboard case before September 22nd you
can get it for half off that means that
with the tab s6 you can get a complete
set up with 256 gigabytes of storage the
Snapdragon 855 processor eight gigabytes
of RAM the stylus and the trackpad
packing keyboard case for a total of
eight hundred and nineteen dollars the
11 inch iPad pro with 256 gigs of
storage the Apple pencil and the smart
Keyboard folio will cost you a thousand
one hundred and seven dollars so you're
saving almost three hundred dollars by
going with the tab s6 instead but while
it looks like an incredible deal on the
spec sheet things might change when we
actually get our hands on it and compare
it side-by-side for example there are
way more apps on the iPad that work
really great compared to some Android
apps that suffer from poor optimization
and resolution issues on Samsung's
tablets so if you want to see us compare
the tab
s62 the iPad pro make sure to click that
circle above to subscribe so you don't
miss out on that video thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]